this is where more than 30 miners mostly
from neighboring Lesotho who work
illegally entered a mine shaft to look
for gold it's an abandoned ventilation
shaft owned by a company called Harmony
gold the workers who went down illegally
never came out a month later the
government says they were killed in a
methane gas explosion it says gas levels
are still too dangerous to look for the
bodies
lost two family members in the mines
[Music]
this group of men told us off camera
some of them mine illegally too they say
they rescued Two Men and Days Later
returned to retrieve three bodies
celebalo shows us this video
his watching mind Vehicles drive off
from the scene he says they threw what
he calls a bomb underground
um
people who were there say a group of
white men arrived while we weren't there
they say that they arrived about 20
minutes later then they heard a Bang
from the hole and after that they sent
us a message and so we left Lesotho to
come here a spokesperson for harmony
gold denies the allegations saying the
company has in the past helped rescue
miners trapped underground those miners
were then arrested for working illegally
the company also says the latest
incident is under criminal investigation
aside from the safety issues associated
with illegal mining many of these miners
belong to gangs and are involved in
often violent turf wars there are
thousands of abandoned mines across
South Africa many of them still contain
gold and minerals but are not
financially viable for industrial mining
they continue to attract informal miners
hoping to make their own fortune
this group calls itself artisanal miners
they also operate illegally and sell the
gold they mine on the black market they
want the government to change its rules
to allow them to work within the law
but until that happens tens of thousands
of unofficial miners remain underground
family Al Jazeera Virginia South Africa